We have lots of ways to describe the good that can sometimes come from bad. A blessing in disguise, a silver lining. But what if the bad that led to the good was truly awful? You could see that his face was starting to balloon to a size where I realized how bad it was that he had gotten hurt. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. There's really just one way to look at a given event. it got in her. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. There's really just one way to look at a given event. A slight change in outcome can change the way we see and interpret an experience.
我们有许多方法来描述有时能从坏事中变出的美好。因祸得福，一线生机。但如果导致好事发生的坏事真的很糟糕呢？你可以看到他的脸开始肿胀起来，大到我意识到他受伤得有多严重。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。对于一个特定的事件，其实只有一种看法。她钻进去了。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。对于一个特定的事件，其实只有一种看法。结果的微小改变就能改变我们看待和解释经历的方式。
This week we have the story of three people who discover that an event the initially viewed as terrible might in fact have been just the opposite. Not awful, but a stroke of unimaginable good luck. Framing and reframing, this week on Hidden Brain. December 21st is the Winter Solstice, the shortest day of the year. It's also the day our story begins. Three people have finished work, each is heading to a metro train station in Washington, DC.
本周我们讲述三个人的故事，他们发现起初被视为糟糕透顶的一件事件，事实上可能恰恰相反。并非糟糕，而是难以想象的绝佳好运气。构建与重新构建，本周收听《隐藏的大脑》。12月21日是冬至，一年中白天最短的日子。这也是我们故事开始的日子。三个人结束了工作，每个人都前往华盛顿特区的一个地铁站。
And it was just before rush hour, I was planning to meet my wife who works a few stations ahead of me. This is Colin Dale, he's at the centre of our story. Colin is 42, happily married. He's got two teenage kids and a successful job as a technology consultant. He's also, as you can hear, originally from England. Colin was the first person in our story to reach the station and board a train. And that's where the trouble started. I do vaguely remember that a group of youth
就在晚高峰之前，我正打算去见我的妻子，她在离我几站远的地方工作。这是科林·戴尔，他是我们故事的核心人物。科林42岁，婚姻幸福。他有两个十几岁的孩子，并且在一家技术咨询公司拥有一份成功的工作。正如你所听到的，他最初也来自英国。科林是我们故事中第一个到达车站并登上列车的人。麻烦就是从那里开始的。我隐约记得有一群年轻人
got on the train and I must have thought that there would be somehow around punctures or aggressive because I remember texting my wife in a panic really to be honest with you don't get on the train. Another woman did get on the train with Colin. Her name is Christian Smith. Christian had made a dash for the train. Another woman did get on the train with Colin. Her name is Kristen Smith. Kristen had made a dash for the train and jumped into the first car, the same one in which Colin was riding. I could tell as soon as I had jumped in that it was a weird situation,
上了车，我当时一定觉得他们会有些扎眼或是咄咄逼人，因为说实话，我记得当时非常惊慌地给妻子发信息，让她别上另一列车。另一个女人和科林一起上了车。她的名字叫克里斯蒂安·史密斯。克里斯蒂安曾冲向列车。另一个女人和科林一起上了车。她的名字叫克里斯汀·史密斯。克里斯汀曾冲向列车，跳进了第一节车厢，也就是科林乘坐的那节车厢。我一跳进去就能看出情况不对劲，
I felt uncomfortable as soon as I got through the doors. The first thing she noticed was a group of boisterous teenagers. It felt like there were a lot of kids on all four seats that surround that middle door of the subway car, and there were also kids standing in the aisle in a way where it was clear they weren't going to make room for people coming on or off. You had to make your way around them.
我一穿过车门就感到很不舒服。她注意到的第一件事是一群喧闹的青少年。感觉地铁车厢中间门周围的所有四个座位上都坐满了孩子，过道上也站着一些孩子，显然他们不会给上车或下车的人腾出地方。你必须绕过他们。
I'm Lori Kaplan, and I head up Audiences' Sites Department at NPR. This is Colin's wife. She's a colleague of mine. Laurie had timed her departure from work, so she'd arrive at her metro station just before Colin's train pulled in. As I was approaching the platform, I texted him to say, I'm here. I'm here, I'm almost here, and he said, don't get on. I had seen these text messages that arrived during my walk that said, don't get on the first train, because we normally get on the first car of the train.
我是洛里·卡普兰，我负责NPR的听众洞察部门。这是科林的妻子。她是我的一位同事。洛里计算好了她离开工作单位的时间，这样她就能在科林的列车进站前到达她的地铁站。当我接近站台时，我给她发短信说，我到了。我到了，我快到了，他说，别上车。我看到了那些在步行途中收到的短信，上面写着，不要坐第一辆车，因为我们通常坐火车的头节车厢。
What happens next on the train and in the days that follow is what our story is about. It's a tragic story, but perhaps it's also a story of profound luck. It all depends on how you frame it, the lens through which you view what happened. Let me start by going back a bit into the lives of Colin and Laurie. The two first met when the company Colin worked for was hired by NPR for a contract project. It wasn't going well. The person who was leading that work said,
接下来在列车上以及随后的几天里发生的事情，就是我们这个故事的主题。这是一个悲剧性的故事，但或许这也是一个充满深厚运气的厚故事。这一切都取决于你如何构架它，通过什么样的视角来看待发生的事情。让我先简单回顾一下科林和洛里的生活。两人最初相遇时，科林工作的那家公司被NPR雇佣来做一个合同项目。进展并不顺利。负责这项工作的人说，
I'm going to Idaho, but if you have any problems, call this guy Colin, he'll help you out. In fact, the project was a mess. So Lori called. She was really mad. Yelling, and I was quite unpleasant, actually. But he fixed the problem and he's been fixing a lot of my problems ever since. Eventually, they got married, had children. Laurie describes Colin this way. He's calm. He cares.
我要去爱达荷州，但如果你有什么问题，给这个叫科林的家伙打电话，他会帮你解决的。事实上，这个项目一团糟。于是洛里打了电话。她真的很生气。大喊大叫，实际上我很不高兴。但他解决了问题，从那以后他就一直在帮我解决很多问题。最终，他们结婚了，有了孩子。洛里这样形容科林。他很冷静。他很有爱心。
He cares a lot. He's a great dad. I think he's all he ever wanted to be. He was probably a dad. He is a fixer and a doer and I'm a doer, so we just do a lot of things together. They're both athletic, especially Colin. From his childhood, he used to bike all over the North
他非常关心别人。他是个好爸爸。我想他拥有了他一直想要的一切。他可能很适合当爸爸。他是一个解决问题的人和行动派，而我也是一个行动派，所以我们只是有很多事情一起做。他们都很热爱运动，尤其是科林。从小他就喜欢在整个北方骑自行车，
of England, that's just what he would do. So he grew up biking and he was a boy scout leader and would kayak. And so he was very active. And then when he moved here, he would bike to work from our house to DC many times a week. And yeah we hike with we hike with our family too so he was very active. You might have noticed that Laurie said Colin was very active.
英格兰，他过去就是这么做的。所以他在骑自行车中长大，他曾是一名童子军领袖，还会划皮划艇。所以他非常活跃。然后当他搬到这里后，他每周多次从我们家骑自行车去华盛顿上班。是的，我们也和家人一起远足，所以他非常活跃。你可能注意到洛里说科林非常活跃。
That's because in the last couple of years he'd been having some trouble. He was having a lot of joint pain and discomfort, and it was just his knees hurt, his arms hurt, his legs hurt, he just had a lot of pain, and so it just made it challenging to bite because it was very uncomfortable. But it was challenging to walk frankly. He would stop sometimes on the weight of the metro,
那是因为在过去几年里他遇到了一些麻烦。他有大量的关节疼痛和不适，只是他的膝盖疼，手臂疼，腿疼，他只是有很多疼痛，所以这让骑自行车变得很有挑战性，因为非常不舒服。坦白说，走路也很具有挑战性。有时他会在地铁的台阶上停下来，
which felt really unusual to me. Colin had tried to figure out what was wrong. He'd seen a lot of doctors, a lot of specialists. Everyone was stumped. Colin was frustrated. And so, when he stepped onto the train that evening, shortly before Christmas, he was taking a break from his quest for an answer. Colin would like to be able to explain what happened on that train ride, but he can't.
这让我觉得很不寻常。科林曾试图弄清楚出了什么问题。他看过很多医生，很多专家。所有人都被难住了。科林感到沮丧。因此，当他在圣诞节前不久的那个傍晚踏上列车时，他正在从寻找答案的征途中抽身歇息。科林很希望能解释在那次列车上发生了什么，但他做不到。
After texting his wife, his memories of the ride are gone. Kristen Smith, on the other hand, has been haunted by memories of that commute. She seshied took a seat and leaned her head up against the window. I have tried to think a lot about what it was that made me turn around and I can't quite remember, but I think it was either a period of awkward silence or I heard scuffling and that made me turn around to look back at the middle of the car. Christian says it was hard to tell exactly what was happening, which it could see that the group of teenagers was surrounding one man.
在给妻子发完短信后，他对那次乘车的记忆便消失了。另一方面，克里斯汀·史密斯一直被那次通勤的记忆所困扰。她坐下并将头靠在窗户上。我一直在努力回想是什么让我回过头去的，我记不太清了，但我想要么是一段尴尬的沉默，要么是我听到了争执声，这让我转过身去看着车厢中间。克里斯蒂安说，很难准确分辨当时发生了什么，她可以看到那群青少年正围着一个男人。
And he had a blue backpack and I remember he had his arms up through the backpack straps with the backpack facing up, and he was shielding himself. He was using the blue backpack as a shield. It was Colin Dale. Christian says he tried to get away. And as he took a step, he got hit in rapid succession, I thought he got hit in rapid succession with maybe two hits and he fell down to the ground and then the kids all stepped away from him and in my mind that felt like
他背着一个蓝色的双肩包，我记得他把胳膊穿过双肩包的背带，双肩包朝上，他在保护自己。他把蓝色双肩包当作盾牌。那是科林·戴尔。克里斯蒂安说他试图逃跑。当他向前迈出一步时，他遭到接连的打击，我想他可能接连挨了大约两次打，然后他倒在了地上，接着孩子们都从他身边退开了，在我的脑海里，这感觉就像
a good thing that the kids had stepped or that the youth had stepped away from him and that it had stopped like the violence had stopped in that moment and I think that was my first thought was just relief that maybe this would stop and they leave him alone now but I didn't realize that he was in such bad shape at that point. I could see his feet sticking out from the between the metro car seats out into the aisle. Colin eventually got up and staggered toward Kristen and another commuter. They tried to comfort him.
一件好事，那些孩子或是那些年轻人从他身边退开了，这一切都停止了，那一刻暴力已经停止了，我想我的第一个念头只是松了一口气，也许这会停止，他们现在会离他远点，但我当时并没有意识到他情况那么糟糕。我可以看到他的双脚从地铁车厢座位之间伸到了过道里。科林最终站起来，踉踉跄跄地走向克里斯汀和另一位通勤者。他们试图安慰他。
The train was nearing Laurie's station. Kristen says without drawing the attention of the teenagers, she tried to let the conductor know what was going on. And there's a little crack between the door and where the door connects to the wall, I guess. And I started saying through the door crack, you have to stop the train, you have to get medical help, you have to get the police, there's an attack. It worked.
列车正在接近洛里的车站。克里斯汀说，在没有引起青少年注意的情况下，她试图让列车员知道发生了什么。门和门与墙连接的地方之间有一条小缝隙，我想是这样。我开始透过门缝说，你得停下列车，你得叫医疗救援，你得叫警察，这里发生袭击了。这起作用了。
When the train came to a stop at the station, the doors to Collins car remained closed. The teenagers panicked. And that's when they turned and there are emergency exit doors at the end of the car, which would have been at the end of the car away from me. And they all turned and they ran down and went through the exit door of the car. Laurie meanwhile was on the escalator. When she reached the platform, she saw that the train had been unloaded. Yeah, I just looked around. He should be here.
当列车在车站停下时，科林所在车厢的门依然关着。这群年轻人惊慌失措。就在那时，他们转过身，车厢尽头有紧急出口门，那应该是在离我较远的车厢尽头。他们全都转身跑了过去，从车厢的逃生门逃走了。与此同时，洛里正在自动扶梯上。当她到达站台时，她看到列车上的人已经下光了。是的，我只是四处看了看。他应该在这里的。
So I walked further down the platform even though he said he was going to get off the first car. I walked all the way to the front and that was the only train car that was closed. The train doors were shut and then I saw Colin on the train. And he looked terrible. He was like a ghost. I saw blood on his face and he started hitting the glass on the front because of the conductor's car, the driver's car. the conductor's car, the driver's car. Saying that's my wife, that's my wife. And they let me on the train, and I took them off the train. And I sat them down on a bench.
所以我沿着站台往前走，尽管他说他要从第一节车厢下车。我一直走到最前面，那是唯一一节关闭的车厢。列车门是关着的，然后我在车上看到了科林。他看起来糟透了。他就像个鬼魂一样。我看到他脸上有血，他开始敲击正面的玻璃，因为那是售票员的车厢，司机的车厢。售票员的车厢，司机的车厢。说着那是我的妻子，那是我的妻子。他们让我上了车，我把他带下了车。我让他坐在一张长椅上。
It was a little bench near the end of the platform. And I put his head down, because I saw his bleeding immediately. One of the Metro police officers approached me and he said we have an ambulance on the way. Colin was in very bad shape. His teeth were shattered. His jaw jotted out to one side like he'd stuffed a balloon into his cheek. He was disoriented.
那是站台尽头附近的一张小长椅。我让他的头垂下，因为我立刻看到了他流血不止。一名地铁警察向我走过来，他说我们有救护车在路上了。科林的状况非常糟糕。他的牙齿碎了。他的下巴向一侧歪去，就像嘴里塞了一个气球一样。他神志不清。
He kept asking the same questions over and over again. He would ask me, was there, was I in an accident on my bike? Was there a terrorist attack? Was there like what happened? He didn't know. He would just look and assess the situation and then ask me. And then he would ask if I was okay. Even when he saw the ambulance, he thought maybe something was happening to me. At the hospital, a team of doctors took over. As soon as he was admitted, they realized he was complaining of neck problems, and so they immediately that evening had done CAT scans and then MRI, a series of MRIs.
他一遍又一遍地问同样的问题。他会问我，我是不是骑自行车出了事故？是不是发生了恐怖袭击？是不是像发生了什么？他不知道。他只是看着并评估情况，然后问我。接着他会问我是否还好。甚至当他看到救护车时，他还以为自己出了什么事。在医院里，一个医生团队接手了。他一入院，他们就意识到他一直在抱怨颈部问题，于是当晚他们立即做了CT扫描和核磁共振，以及一系列核磁共振检查。
And this is where our story takes a turn. Up to this point, I think most of us would agree that what happened to Colin was terrible and unprovoked brutal attack that left him badly in short and his wife, children, and witnesses traumatized. It's hard to frame the incident any other way. But what comes next may change your mind. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. After a brutal assault on a DC metro train, Colin Dale is in the hospital. Surgeons are preparing to repair his jaw with a titanium plate. He's wearing a brace for neck pain and waiting for scan results to figure out whether the
故事就在这里发生了转折。在此之前，我想我们大多数人都会同意，科林遭遇的是一起可怕且无端、残忍的袭击，导致他严重受损，他的妻子、孩子和目击者也受到了心灵创伤。很难以任何其他方式来看待这起事件。但接下来的内容可能会改变你的看法。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。在华盛顿特区地铁列车上遭遇残忍袭击后，科林·戴尔住进了医院。外科医生正准备用钛板修复他的下巴。他戴着颈托来缓解颈部疼痛，并等待扫描结果以确定
attack caused any further harm. Colin says a doctor walked into the room. Someone, you know, he's wearing a blue outfit looked like he fit in a hospital, came by my bed with a printout of the MRI and I'd had a neck brace on and he said, well, you know, Mr. Day, you can take the neck brace off, but I just want to show you this part on the MRI, it looks like you have a tumour in your spinal cord. A tumour, not a bruise or a fracture, but something else entirely. There was a contrast, there was a lump inside of his spinal cord and a cervical spine. I just happened to have a neck. And they said this is inside and it's very large and it really needs to come out.
袭击是否造成了进一步的伤害。科林说一名医生走进了房间。你知道，有个穿着蓝色衣服、看起来像是在医院工作的人，拿着核磁共振打印件来到我的床边，当时我戴着颈托，他说，嗯，你知道，戴尔先生，你可以把颈托摘下来，但我只是想向你展示核磁共振上的这个部分，看起来你的脊髓里有一个肿瘤。肿瘤，不是瘀伤或骨折，而是完全不同的东西。有一个造影剂对比，他的脊髓和颈椎内部有一个肿块。我正好有一个脖子。他们说这个在里面而且非常大，真的需要切除。
Instantly, this explained everything. The joint pain, Collins' balance issues, his fatigue, it was cancer and it was almost too late. and it was almost too late. What was revealed to us was even more dire, you know, as it had been, as it was growing, it had been just another few millimeters further. He would have already, he would have affected his ability to breathe. So... So, let's think about that train ride again, the brutal assault. Was it a tragedy? Or was it the luckiest ride of his life? It led to a life-saving diagnosis, but it came at
瞬间，这一切都有了合理的解释。关节疼痛、科林的平衡问题、疲劳，这是癌症，而且几乎为时已晚。而且几乎为时已晚。向我们揭示的情况甚至更加可怕，你知道，随着它的生长，它本已再长出几毫米。他就会，他本会影响他的呼吸能力。所以……所以，让我们再次回想那次列车之旅，那场残酷的袭击。这是一场悲剧吗？还是他一生中最幸运的一次乘车？它带来了一个救命的诊断，但代价是
great cost. In a situation like this, does the good outweigh the bad? Can bad ever come to be seen as good? When I contacted Kristen Smith, the witness for the story, I discovered she wasn't aware of what had happened to Colin and Laurie after the attack. The story was hard for Kristen to hear, in part because her uncle had just died of a brain tumor. It was also such a quick thing we found out he was sick only maybe two and a half, three months ago, and that was gone.
巨大的代价。在这样的情况下，好事能压过坏事吗？坏事最终能被视为好事吗？当我联系到这个故事的目击者克里斯汀·史密斯时，我发现她并不知道科林和洛里在袭击发生后遭遇了什么。这个故事对克里斯汀来说很难接受，部分原因是因为她的叔叔刚刚死于脑瘤。这也是一个很快的过程，我们发现他生病大概只有两个半、三个月前，然后人就没了。
And, um, it's crazy the thing that I had maybe have been attacked on a Metro, they would have caught it sooner and stopped it. I don't know if I'll do such a strange. But as the information sank in, Christian began to reframe the way she viewed the attack on Colin. I think something did come, something good to come from it, but I'm still left with the feeling of maybe even, well, no I guess that's not true. If I had stopped the attack sooner, I was thinking he probably would have gone to the hospital and they still would have found the tumor, but maybe that's not true. Maybe he had to be hurt to a degree that they really were investigating him deeply to find the tumor.
而且，嗯，这太疯狂了，我可能在地铁上遭遇袭击这件事，他们能更早地发现并阻止它。我不知道自己是否会做出如此奇怪的举动。但随着信息深入脑海，克里斯蒂安开始重新构建她对科林遭遇袭击的看法。我想确实有什么事情发生了，有好事从中诞生，但我仍然留有一种感觉，也许甚至，不，我想那不是真的。如果我能早点阻止袭击，我曾想他可能会去医院，他们仍然会发现肿瘤，但也许那不是真的。也许他必须受到一定程度的伤害，他们才会真正对他的身体进行深入检查以发现肿瘤。
Exactly one month after being attacked on the train, Colin underwent a dangerous and difficult surgery to remove the cancerous tumor in his spine. By most measures, it was a huge success. Colin survived and he wasn't paralyzed, which was something the doctor's fear it might happen. But he was very far from his old self. I felt like my legs were floating in space, like several inches up from the bed and several inches over and feel heat, cold, and some strange electrical twinges, large parts of his body were numb. Other parts of his body were racked by endless pain. And that's difficult when he even taking a shower and feeling the water in his body. It will cause him to scream and my son's bedroom is next
在地铁上遭遇袭击整整一个月后，科林接受了一台危险而困难的手术，切除了他脊柱中的恶性肿瘤。从大多数标准来看，这是一次巨大的成功。科林活了下来，而且没有瘫痪，这是医生们曾害怕可能会发生的事情。但他离曾经的自己还有很长一段距离。我觉得我的腿在太空中漂浮，就像离床面好几英寸高，还向旁边偏移了几英寸，能感受到热、冷和一些奇怪的触电感，他身体的大部分都麻木了。他身体的其他部分则被无尽的痛苦折磨着。这很困难，当他甚至在洗淋浴并感受水流打在身体上时。这会让他尖叫，我儿子的卧室就在
to the shower and that's difficult for the family, just empathizing with his pain. So this is where the Dales are now. They're struggling to recover and make sense of a series of troubling and intertwined events. When I first heard about Colin and Laurie and the strange path to his diagnosis, I, the outsider, immediately thought of the train attack as a blessing in disguise. Our witness Christian had a more nuanced view, tinted by her own actions that day. As for Laurie, she says she tries to see the good in what happened, she mentions unexpected moments of kindness she encountered,
淋浴间旁边，这对家人来说很难，只能对他的痛苦感同身受。这就是戴尔一夫妇目前的处境。他们正在艰难地恢复，并试图理清一系列令人困扰且交织在一起的事件。当我第一次听到科林和洛里的故事以及他确诊的奇怪经历时，我这个局外人立刻把地铁袭击视为因祸得福。我们的目击者克里斯蒂安有着更细腻的看法，这受到她那天行为的影响。至于洛里，她说她试着从发生的事情中看到美好，她提到了她遇到的意想不到的善良时刻，
like the time a school crossing guard, a stranger, dropped off a meal on her porch. But for Laurie and Colin, what happened on the train is still a recurring trauma. That's really hard because, you know, there's a sense of reliving it every day. When you go every day to the same spot and get on the train at the same spot where your husband was lying down in his blood on his backpack. Did it have any silver linings at all? Everyone, you know, everyone refers to what happened to Colin oh well you got your diagnosis and you got the cancer out what is
比如一个学校的过街交警，一个陌生人，在她的门廊上放下了一顿饭。但对于洛里和科林来说，地铁上发生的事情仍然是一个挥之不去的创伤。这真的很艰难，因为，你知道，有一种每天都在重温这一切的感觉。当你每天都去同一个地方，在你的丈夫躺在血泊中和背包上的同一个地方上车时。这完全算得上一线生机吗？每个人，你知道，每个人都提到科林遭遇的事情，哦，好吧，你确诊了，你切除了癌症，这一切都
over like well we sure would have hoped that that could have been diagnosed earlier in some other way it's not that most ideal way to have that diagnosed but we're glad that he's alive and has a good... and he... they... the... what can we say? That cancer is out, it doesn't seem to be growing, it doesn't seem to be growing back, he has a positive... a relatively positive outlook. So I can't help but think that you wouldn't have gotten that scan down when you did, if it hadn't been for the incident. But the incident was truly horrible. I don't know how to process that.
结束了，就像，好吧，我们当然希望能够更早地通过其他方式诊断出来，这不是最理想的诊断方式，但我们很高兴他活着并且有一个好……并且他……他们……他们……我们能说什么呢？癌症切除了，似乎没有在生长，似乎没有复出，他有一种积极的……相对积极的展望。所以我不得不认为，如果没有这次事件，你不可能在那时做那种扫描。但那场事件真的太可怕了。我不知道该如何处理这件事。
He and me both. I asked Colin how he views what happened. Colin's considered the many ways of seeing what's happened. Was it coincidence? The intervention of a higher power? Luck? For now, Colin says, the frame of understanding that feels most right to him is simply acknowledging that life is random. It means he does a lot of things about this story that just line up almost too perfectly.
我和他都有同感。我问科林他是如何看待发生的事情的。科林思考了看待所发生事情的多种方式。这是巧合吗？更高力量的干预？运气？目前，科林说，让他感觉最正确的理解框架只是承认生活是随机的。这意味着关于这个故事，他有很多事情只是排布得几乎完美。
If this was an episode of a TV show, you'd be like, yeah, sure. Yeah, I got it. I don't know. I do like the random in many ways that sort of makes my universe more comfortable. And maybe that's the most powerful truth in this tale. We all see things through our own lens and we settle on the vision that gives us the greatest sense of comfort. When things happen to us, we sift and re-sift information to shape how we see the world. Imagine a group of people sitting around a campfire. One might see the fire as beautiful, the flames perhaps sparking memories of
如果这是一部电视剧的一集，你大概会觉得，好吧，确实。好吧，我懂了。我不知道。在许多方面我确实喜欢这种随机性，它某种程度上让我的宇宙更舒适。也许这就是这个故事中最强大的真相。我们都通过自己的镜头来看待事物，并且我们最终会接受能带给我们最大安慰的愿景。当事情发生在我们身上时，我们筛选并重新筛选信息，以塑造我们看待世界的方式。想象一群人围坐在篝火旁。一个人可能会把火看作是美丽的，火焰或许能激发出关于
childhood and family and friends. Another person who'd suffered serious burn injuries might see the very same fire as ugly and dangerous. There's no one reality, it's all in the framing. As for the dails, long before Collins train assault and tumour, the family had planned a trip, a walking tour across the whole of England from coast to coast, 260 miles on a rugged trail. They couldn't cancel, so they decided to go for it, despite everything that had happened. And the the lures that you pick up are stone from from the west coast and you you walk it across and then you put it in the east coast when you go to the other side. And why do you carry a rock from west to east? What's the story?
童年、家庭和朋友的回忆。而另一个经历过严重烧伤的人可能会把这同一场火看作是丑陋且危险的。没有唯一的现实，一切都在于构架。至于戴尔一家，早在科林的列车遇袭和肿瘤发作之前，全家就计划好了一次旅行，一次从东海岸到西海岸、横穿整个英国的徒步之旅，在一条崎岖的小路上走260英里。他们无法取消，所以决定不管发生什么都要去实现它。而你捡拾的石头来自西海岸的石头，你把它带着走过，然后当你去到另一边时把它放在东海岸。你为什么要带着一块石头从西到东？这是个什么故事？
It just just shows that you've made it, you know, it's just a symbolic gesture to mark your the end of that journey. For Colin, of course, this will be a milestone in his recovery, a chance to think. Because the way we see something isn't always how it really is. This week's episode was produced and edited by Jenny Schmidt. Our staff also includes Maggie Penman, Chris Benderef, Karamogar Galison and René Clarre. Our supervising producer is Tara Boyle. Last week we began acknowledging the unsung heroes who are vital to the success of this show, but aren't typically in the credits. This week, our unsung hero is Nikela Matthews.
这只是表明你成功做到了，你知道，这只是一个象征性的手势，用来标志你那段旅程的结束。当然，对科林来说，这将是他康复过程中的一个里程碑，一个思考的机会。因为我们看待事物的方式并不总是它真实的样子。本周的节目由珍妮·施密特制作和剪辑。我们的员工还包括玛吉·佩恩曼、克里斯·本德雷夫、卡拉莫加·加利森和勒内·克拉雷。我们的监督制作人是塔拉·博伊尔。上周我们开始表彰对本节目成功至关重要、但通常不在演职员表中的幕后英雄。本周，我们的幕后英雄是尼克拉·马修斯。
Nikela sits right near the Hidden Brain staff here at NPR, and she's become something of an honorary team member. She helps us reach new audiences through Facebook and Twitter, and we so appreciate her creative and collegial spirit. Thanks, Nikola. Speaking of Facebook and Twitter, you can find more of my reporting on social media, along with great videos and animations that bring to life the research we highlight on Hidden Brain. Check them out, and while you're there, we'd love it if you would share this episode and our stories, with friends who you think would enjoy our show.
尼克拉就坐在NPR这里的《隐藏的大脑》员工附近，她已经成为了团队的荣誉成员。她通过Facebook和Twitter帮助我们接触新的受众，我们非常感谢她富有创造力和同事精神的精神。谢谢你，尼克拉。说到Facebook和Twitter，你可以在社交媒体上找到更多我的报道，以及让我们在《隐藏的大脑》中强调的研究生动展现的精彩视频和动画。去看看吧，当你在那里的时候，如果你能把这一集和我们的故事分享给那些你认为会喜欢我们节目的朋友，我们会很高兴。
I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是香卡·韦丹塔姆，这里是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。